Because so many of you Fellow Scholars have
requested it, we had a video on one of the
best papers in the year in my opinion, which
is a work called Gaussian Splatting. And I am
absolutely speechless by how quickly things are
unfolding around it. I think you will be too. So,
what does this do? Well, just imagine grabbing
your smartphone, taking a few images or videos
of real places, and then, we could create
a virtual version of them and play in them
in real time. And it does exactly that. And
these scenes come out really really detailed.
Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
And the key thing here is that this is
a handcrafted technique that is easy
to implement. And now, some publicly available
applications already have it. This one does. Yes,
the dream is coming true, we might just play
in a virtual copy of the real world very soon.
Especially that it is available in Unreal
Engine too through a paid plugin, though
I am sure that free versions will pop up very
soon too. In fact, things are going so quickly,
I wouldn’t be surprised if by the time this
video appears, it is already available for free.
And it gets even better. Way better! For instance,
we know that text to image is possible, but we are
talking about 3D virtual worlds here. So, oh my.
It has been just a few months of this paper being
out, can that really be? Follow up papers are
already popping up. Wait a second. This is text to
3D. We write something, and out comes 3D geometry.
Our last episode was on exactly that, and it is
already being surpassed. What is happening? Wow.
Well, what is happening is that Gaussian Splatting
is already being used to improve these techniques.
Hmm, in many cases, I see more detailed geometry
being produced. And all this in just a couple of
months and one more paper down the line. So cool!
But it doesn’t end there. Not even
close. Goodness! Here is another
paper which is able to perform
image to 3D. One photo goes in,
and out comes 3D geometry. I already see that it
converges to a solution much quicker than earlier,
neural radiance fields-based solutions,
that is fantastic news, but come on,
what can it do? Wow, it really does it. In
goes the image, and out comes the 3D model.
And it gets better. Then, we can even really
put these little models into our virtual worlds,
and animate them. And all this process takes…how
long exactly? The previous paper we looked at took
40 minutes, so what about this one? Now
hold on to your papers Fellow Scholars,
because it is two minutes. This is incredible!
A 20x speedup in just one paper. I really don’t
know what to say here. In the first step, it
lines up the Gaussians, little mathematical
lumps to match the shape of the character
or object, and then, in the second step,
it slowly refines the textures as well. And this
one runs on a single consumer graphics card, this
is what does it in two minutes per object. Haha!
This work is a real match for Two Minute Papers.
No wonder these papers caught the imagination of
you Fellow Scholars. It gets even better. It can
even reproduce photorealistic faces reasonably
well with just 25 photos as an input, and…whoa!
Here, you can even animate these inputs. So not
only creating virtual worlds from the real world,
but we can even let our imagination run wild and
create absolutely anything out of it. I love it.
Now, just one more thing. I know some
of you Fellow Scholars are asking,
okay but what is Gaussian Splatting? What
does that even mean? Now the Gaussian part
means that objects in this scene will be
represented as a sum of many little waves.
And splatting is a way of throwing these
little waves from the 3D virtual world
at our 2D screen and computing what they
should really look like. And this simple,
but effective idea taking the world by storm.
A handcrafted technique. Powered not by AI, but
by human ingenuity. Once again, the papers coming
alive in the real world. What a time to be alive!